Tyler: Ever since the incident
Mamrie: Which one?
Tyler: Mamrie, why you've got a model?
Mamrie: I'm bringing Beanz into the mix
Tyler: This is a foursome to be reckoned with
Grace: [awkwardly] Squad goals
*track scratch*
Grace: You know what they say?
Tyler: Okay MOM
Grace: Hello, I'm here with Tyler Oakley and Mamrie Hart!
*Dramatic thud*
Mamrie: [is needy] Tyler will you open this?
Tyler: [in mock exasperation] Oh my god
Grace: We are joined by celebrity guest Beanz Heart
Tyler: [laughing] I was like "who's here?"
*Another dramatic thud*
Grace: I have resurrected a game that we played
on the Grace Helbig show on E! called: uh..
"Boyband or Condom Brand"
I thought it'd be really fun to play with Mamrie and Tyler
because I feel like you guys might know a lot about
Both or neither of those things
Tyler: Safe sex
Mamrie: How dare you, I'm in the classical films and unsafe sex [laughter]
Grace: I'm gonna list off a–uh–title and they have to ring in and–
Tyler: [interrupting] How do we ring in?
Mamrie: what do we–
Tyler: Last time we had shakers
Grace: I know
[flashback] Mamrie: Cowbell! *bangs flask*
Mamrie: Yep!
-Tyler: I want a fun prop!
Tyler: *shakes cocktail shaker*
Grace and Mamrie in unison: OOOOOOOOOH
Grace: This time you guys have to create your buzzer noises
Mamrie: *inaudible laughter
Tyler: ooo-OOOO!
Mamrie: That's very similar to my classic noise!
Tyler: *vigorously* ooo-OOOOOOOO
*laughter*
Grace: You guys have to choose a very short boyband lyric
as your ring-in a phrase
Tyler: *nasally* bye bye bye
Grace: "my my my"? Is that what you just said?
TyIer: I said "bye bye bye"
*replays scene*
Tyler: Mah-mah-myyee
Mamrie: I think she meant "make one up"
Tyler: Ooh!
Grace: Yeah
Mamrie: Here's mine
Ouch! That's my heart!
Grace: *enthusiastically* That's great!
Tyler what's your boyband?
Tyler: [caught off-guard] Umm.. f**kin'
Grace: That's great
Mamrie: Perfect!
Tyler: *cackle*
Grace: By the end of this game the person that is the loser
Gets drawn on by the winner a boyband facial hair
Mamrie: ooooh
Grace: Because [there's] always a certain member of a boy band that has very very specific unflattering facial hair
Here we go, you guys both remember your buzzer noises?
Tyler: Umm.. f**kin'
Mamrie: Ouch! That's my heart
Wait- how- what- is it a question?
Grace: I'm giving you a name. And you have to ring in
And you just say if it's a condom brand or a boyband
Tyler: Oh yeah
Code Red
Mamrie: Oh! Oh! Ouch! That's my heart!
Tyler: Um.. f**kin'
Grace: Mamrie!
Mamrie: Condom
Grace: It's a boy band
Mamrie: *gasp*
Grace: Yeah, here's the photo of Code Red
Grace: Mamrie you have negative one
Tyler: Yeah
Mamrie: *appalled* Negative one?
Grace: Kimono
Tyler: [wtf?] Um.. f**kin'
That's a condom
Grace: It is a condom!
Mamrie: Kimono is a condom?
Grace: Yeah!
Mamrie: Oh because you wrap it up tightly like a kimono!
Mamrie: It should be "Kum-on-oh"
Tyler: Oh!
Mamrie: Come? Oh no! Come? OH NO! I'm a condom!
Grace: Caught in the Act
Mamrie: Ouch! That's my heart
Grace: Mamrie
Mamrie: Boyband??? [what am I doing]
Grace: *excitedly* That's a boyband! Yes! Correct!
Tyler: Really?
Grace: Yeah! Mamrie has zero points cause she caught herself up and Tyler has one
Grace: Night Light
[subtitle note: Goddamit Grace, your videos move so quickly, I can't keep up]
Tyler: Um.. F**kin'
Condom!
Mamrie: Yeah for sure.
Tyler: Got to be, got to be, got to be, got to be, got to be
Grace: It's a condom
Tyler: Yes!
Mamrie: *lying* It's also a boyband, though
Grace: *believing this bullsh*** Is it?
Tyler: Why you gotta to lie?
Mamrie: It might have been regional–
Tyler: *not having it* Name seven singles
Mamrie: "You better believe", "Girl don't lie to me"
"My heart my life, my art, my strife"
"Biceps" about bicuriousness
"Um.. f**kin' "
"Shart attack" and "Ouch! That's my heart!"
Grace: I don't know why they didn't succeed
Blue
Mamrie: Oh- Ouch! That's my heart!
Grace and Tyler: *hysterical laughter*
*Grace does some editing bullsh** and replays "Oh- Ouch!" over and over and Tyler's Laughter*
Mamrie: That's.. a.. boyband!
No, it's a condom! It's a condom brand!
- - Hey guys, this is Editing Grace,
right now in editing this video I realized that
I lied to Mamrie here, and actually Blue is the name of a boy band, look, here's the photo
Yeah, my bad. No one tell Mamrie - -
Mamrie: Where's my dog?
Tyler: She's gone.
Grace: Okay, ready? Last couple
C Note
Tyler: Um.. F**kin'
Grace: *laughing*Tyler
It's got to be..
Mamrie: *Mouthing Boyband*
Tyler: It's- It's got to be a band!
Grace: That's a boyband! Yes! C Note is a boyband!
Crown
Mamrie: Oh.. Ouch! That's my heart!
Condom?
Grace: It's a condom! Yeah!
Mamrie: Yeah, you put it on top of a king.
Grace: Now, this has been really fun. We're gonna pretend all the points haven't mattered at all
and this is the final final question that determines it all
Another Bad Creation
Tyler: Um.. f**kin'
Mamrie: No!
Grace: *laughing* Tyler
Mamrie: Are you kidding me?
Tyler: *offended* What do you mean "are you kidding me?"
It's got to be..
A boyband
A Christian boyband
Mamrie: Can I steal if I name three songs by them?
Grace: I have no thing to know..
Tyler: No! No, mom!
Mamrie: "Playground", "Iesha", "I missed the bus"
ABC BBD!
Mamrie: *singing* "Iesha.. She was the girl I never had
And I'd like to get to know her betta"
You guys remember: "at the playground". You know?
Tyler: *S H O O K* Are you casting a spell?
Mamrie: Playground!
Tyler: Is it a boyband or a condom?
Mamrie: They were a bunch of black boys, in the 90's..
Grace: It's a boyband
Tyler: Well, I got the point, Mamrie.
Grace: I know, but I feel like Mamrie really stole a point from you–
Tyler: You can't go for a steal!
Grace: I think what It's gonna happen is you both get an opportunity to draw a boyband facial hair on each other
Tyler: *awkward mumble*
Mamrie: Relax that face. Relax it!
Tyler: Momrie-
Mamrie: Love yourself
Grace: This is the weirdest therapy session I've ever been a part of
Mamrie: Okay, I'm done with you
Tyler: I think I'm done with you!
Grace: These are the final products take a look
at your beautiful faces
Grace: *laughing* Tyler you look– *incoherent*
Mamrie: Relax your face
Tyler: *cackling*
Grace: Thank you guys for participating in–
Mamrie: I don't even know what's happening on my face right now.
Grace: None of us do!
My face is really out of focus but
We're participating in Condom Brand or boyband. Go subscribe to Tyler we shot a video over there and subscribe to Mamrie
They shot a hilarious video and also they subjected themselves to this kind of treatment so friendship
Grace: I don't know
Tyler: They couldn't even see it, they couldn't even see it.
Grace: What were you doing?
Tyler: Making out!
Tyler: Can I drink?
Grace: Of course you can you're home already! You're fine!
Tyler: What'd you call me, "homo ready?"
Tyler: You have no idea!
Mamrie and Grace: *Hysterical laughter*